what do we think of the Trudeau uh  mention of his love of Communism no like  the the comparison that what's the space  is his father oh like it's like this I  mean the pictures are funny the pictures  are funny yeah I mean and it's like  there's weird history that aligns this  you know like I like my conspiracy  didn't this mother meet I think that's  what it was yeah like numerous times I I  think it's funny because like I was  reading a Snopes thing and it's like  Trudeau's mother did beat with Castro  and it was around the time like it was  like in a similar time frame to when he  may have been you know born but I think  they're saying it was a couple years  before anyway they they look quite a bit  alike  yeah he doesn't look like his father so  it doesn't look like he doesn't that's  for sure yeah no he's clearly fond of  the ideology so maybe Fidel Castro was a  Milkman in Canada yeah you know maybe  he's you know trying to grab onto his  like his father's Legacy it's the